hi everyone my name is jenny lanier and
i'm with the ibm cloud team
let's talk about how to deploy and
manage applications
in ibm cloud code engine before we begin
let's first talk about what an
application is
an application is any piece of code that
is typically meant to run and respond to
incoming requests
such as a web server while it's also
possible to have an application running
even without incoming requests
we're going to focus on the more common
case
with that definition let's jump right
into deploying an application
from this code engine overview page
you'll see that you can immediately
deploy a container image
that you've already built by using this
quick start dialog
you'll see that the image name is
pre-populated with a sample container
image name
so let's just go ahead and hit start
creating
on this page you'll see that there are
some options available
but let's keep this really simple just
using the defaults for everything
including the name of the application so
since we're not going to change anything
let's just go ahead and hit the create
button to actually do it
deploying the app will take a second or
two so let's discuss what's going on
behind the scenes
first code engine will download the
image you provided and then deploy that
to the code engine runtime
since applications are meant to accept
requests it will also set up all of the
networking infrastructure necessary
to route the request to your application
let's go to the runtime tab to see what
kind of runtime configurations are
available to us
notice on here you can control things
like the amount of memory and cpu
allocated for each instance of your app
you can also control incoming requests
and automatically terminate
any request after a certain amount of
time the concurrency value controls how
many requests your app can handle at one
time
and once that limit is reached code
engine will create additional instances
to handle the load
likewise as the load decreases it will
shut down
unneeded instances to automatically
manage the scaling of your application
for you finally notice the final two
config options
min scale and max scale this allows you
to control that scaling we just talked
about even down to zero instances if
there are no incoming requests
but you're in full control of the lower
and upper bounds of this scaling
including having a certain number of
instances always running if needed
notice the app is now ready so let's go
ahead and see what it looks like by
pressing the
application url button
notice the url starts with https so the
application is automatically secured
with tls
now let's pause here for a moment think
about what we just did
we deployed a secure internet-facing
application
that will automatically scale up and
down with traffic
even to xero so you don't have to pay
when your app is idle
and we did all of this with simply the
name of our container image
if you're familiar with platforms like
kubernetes think about how long it would
have taken you to set up
all of the infrastructure needed to do
that the pods
deployments replicate sets load
balancers ingress
that's a lot of work reduced down to one
trivial step
and that's the simplified developer
experience that code engine offers
and to be honest the developers should
expect
that's all the time we have for today
but hopefully you found this quick walk
through of how to manage applications in
code engine
exciting and i encourage you to look at
our other videos to see more key code
engine features